it is so nice to see you um
congratulations nominated performing
tonight yeah all the things doubled
lucky and you'll have your your special
sidekick with you tonight has been ryan
hurd yeah we're performing our song off
my new record it's called i can't love
you anymore and it's just a real love
song but it's funny and i'm so excited
it's our first time performing it live
so that is so cool okay what's the real
love story like at home behind the
scenes off the gram not performing at an
awards show between the two of you i
mean it's easy we've been together so
long we have a son who's two now but we
you know we have our moments for sure
that aren't like rainbows and sunshine
but we just laugh our way through it
because we know that like we're gonna be
in this until the end and we better get
it together and this song is like
exactly that it's narrating our weird
ass love story
which is so cool and i love like any
time i listen to y'all's music i've told
you before i love hearing your voice pop
onto his album and vice ver you know so
it's a beautiful thing that you guys are
doing how do you navigate both being on
tour promoting a new album that's got to
be a lot especially you know when you're
both in the industry you're married to
each other and now you got a little one
we've had years where it's been hard and
we're still like trying to find that i
think we're better now at finding the
balance of like home time and work time
and we're better at like standing our
ground on our personal life than we used
to be because i think we've earned it
now but um no i mean we have our
struggles but i think that we love each
other i will always support his dream of
doing this artist thing his songwriter
dream and vice versa and so i just know
like we can kind of make it through
anything because this is a tough
industry to like
stay married in and even find love in
and so i feel like you all have done it
hit the jackpot so
everything else is like clear skies and
you are starting your tour in june yeah
what can fans expect to see from this
tour of yours that you're embarking on
well the majority of it uh the venues
are amphitheaters so it'll be outside
hopefully not weather like tonight right
yeah but we tried to keep it outdoorsy
and vibey because the record is very
much that it's very organic
styles and music
yeah but it felt very nature based just
we wrote the album in hawaii and so it
just felt right to do these outdoor
venues but um yeah it's going to be so
fun a lot of like the new album will be
showcased but then we'll put some like
oldies and fan favorites in there and
maybe a cover or something hey
and my openers are like
the best so
i have rust and kelly i have uh joy a
lot of [ __ ] i don't know if she's here
but uh i've got britney spencer who's oh
bro also wayne up tonight and um lone
bella like there's a ton of amazing acts
coming out
[Music]